APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
Hey everyone.
My name is Aparna.
I'm a Product Manager
at Google.
I have Roy and Iein with me.
We are from the Knowledge Team
at Google, so this is the
first time our team is doing
these developer sessions at
I/O around structured
data and knowledge.
So we hope you like it, and let
us know what you think for
the next year.
So our talk today is about
bringing relevant information
from the inbox to the search box
and new experiences like
Google Now.
How many of you use Google
Now or have tried it?
OK, all right.
And we're going to talk about
how both as users, you can see
some of the new features we
are building and kinds of
problems that we are trying to
solve, but also from the
developer angle.
Like I said, we'll start with
the user experience.
We'll give you a sense of the
user problems we're trying to
solve, features we're building,
maybe throw in a few
demos, and then switch gears
and say, OK, how can you as
developers be part of
this experience?
How many of you attended the
keynote yesterday morning?
How many of you saw
the search, the
conversational search?
How many of you thought
it was not bad?
Really good?
OK.
So you saw Amit and Johanna
give you a glimpse of the
future of search and
where we are going.
And in this talk, I'll go a
little bit deeper and show you
some of these examples of how
we are pushing the edge in
terms of saying, look, the
future of search is being
conversational and
an assistant.
So for the next few moments, I'm
going to treat this half
of the room as my user
half and this half as
my developer half.
So a quick question
to the user half.
How many of you look
for information
in your emails often?
And question for the
developer half.
Do you send information to
your users, important
information, in the emails--
confirmations, notifications,
stuff that you
want them to remember?
So here's the problem.
You guys are sending information
to these guys, but
then what's happening is this.
So is the person next to you, so
is that guy behind you, and
that woman in the back, she's
sending email too.
And before you know it, these
guys are getting flooded with
all of these emails and
important information, but
it's really impossible for you
to find that one single
nugget, one single answer, one
single piece of information
that you need at the
time you need it.
And to make it really concrete,
let me give you a
specific personal example.
So this morning I woke up, I
had one simple question.
What hotel am I staying at?
So you see I have a flight
coming up tomorrow morning, an
early morning flight, and I
have this talk, and I have
another event this evening.
I figured I should just stay
the night in the city.
So I wanted to mention my hotel
information to my husband.
It took me five steps just
to get to that answer.
So first step, you can't see
this here, but I'll talk you
through it.
The first step is I had to
actually swipe past all these
goddamn apps on my phone
and then open Gmail.
The second step, I had to map
the natural question that
popped up in my head.
I had to say, what hotel
am I staying at?
And then turn this into this
robotic set of keywords that I
thought Google could
understand.
So I had to say, OK, maybe I
should say "hotel" and the
provider that actually
sent me that email.
That's the second step.
And then third step, I basically
had to say, well,
now I have to make sure that I
peck at my keyboard and type
these queries on a tiny device,
and make sure that I'm
not doing any typos because it's
a pain to type it again.
Fourth step, then I see a bunch
of these email results.
They all look the same, and I
have to make a guess and say,
maybe one of these emails
has an answer.
Then comes the final step and
say, OK, I click open the
email, wade past all the
information, all the words
that I don't quite need, just to
get that one single answer
which says, it's the
Marriott next door.
Five steps just to get
to that answer.
We think it should be much
easier, and those of who saw
the keynote know that one of the
ways that we want to make
it easier is say, you
ask a question--
in fact, you speak your
mind to the phone--
and we get you the answer.
One single step.
Because by the time I'm done
with these five steps this
morning, my husband was on the
fifth page of Hacker News.
I want it to be in
one single shot.
So we said, OK.
This morning, I came in and
said, team, we must fix this.
And in the last few hours,
we've basically solved
everything.
Kidding, of course.
If you think about it, going
from a question to an answer
in one step requires us to be
solving really hard problems
from the technical side.
First hard problem we'll
have to solve is speech
recognition, understanding
what you're
saying to the phone.
The second hard problem we'll
have to solve is understanding
natural language.
It's hard enough to
understand speech.
Then we have to add
natural language.
And then the third hard problem
we have to solve is
semantic understanding, or
understanding structure enough
to say, when you say, what hotel
am I staying at, we mean
that there's a hotel, there's
a name to the hotel, and
there's an address, and
there's a phone
number and so on.
Very structured information.
These are hard problems, but
I'd much rather let Google
solve these hard problems
than me as a user.
Like I said, speech, natural
language, structured data
understanding.
Now, why is it an important
problem to solve?
If you think about it, during
the course of a typical day--
not a day that you're at Google
I/O, a typical day--
you have lots of questions,
and you want fast answers.
Imagine if each of these
questions took several steps,
you'd be spending a lot of time
just futzing around with
the data that you have.
And you see some of these
questions here.
Some of these questions are
coming from our Knowledge
Graph, and they can be answered
from the Knowledge
Graph that we're building.
And if you attended some of
the structured data talks
earlier today, you know we're
investing in building out this
Knowledge Graph, understanding
things, understanding
places, and so on.
500 million entities
and growing.
But then, not all answers
come from that, right?
So some of these answers
do come from your own
information, let's say your
emails or your calendar.
And we want to be able to help
you go from the question to
answer in one step for those
answers as well.
In some cases--
not all cases, but in some
cases, when the context is
right, in fact, we actually
shouldn't even have to wait
for you to ask that question.
You have a special order that
you're waiting for, or you
just ordered it and
that shipped.
You should just be able to say,
look, the package that
you're waiting for has shipped,
and this is Google
Now for those of you who
are trying it out.
Let me actually switch gears to
a demo so we can actually
show some of these in action.
I'm going to first dare the
Wi-Fi gods here and see if we
can pull it off, the Voice
Search on a phone.
So as I mentioned earlier, I
have this flight coming up
tomorrow morning, and I have a
lunch meeting with a client,
and I just don't want
to be late to it.
So I can say something like,
when is my restaurant
reservation?
COMPUTER VOICE: You have a
reservation for Agnelini
Osteria, 1200 hours
PM tomorrow.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: So I can
see that I see the restaurant
reservation right away.
I don't have to futz
with my phone.
The answer comes
up right away.
And then I say, OK, so it's at
12 o'clock, it's not too bad.
But then, wait.
When does my flight get there?
So I can ask something like,
when does my flight land?
COMPUTER VOICE: Virgin America
Flight 1930 from SFO to LAX
arrives at 9:03 AM tomorrow.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: I
can hear the answer.
I can also see the answer
right away.
And then say, OK, look, unless
I'm paranoid, I have plenty of
time to get to the restaurant.
But I am paranoid, so I'm going
to wonder, is there
traffic between the airport
to the restaurant?
So I can now say something like,
how far is it from LAX
to Angelini Osteria?
COMPUTER VOICE: The drive from
Los Angeles International
Airport to Angelini Osteria
is 12.6 miles.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: So I
can see it's 12.6 miles.
It's 30 minutes, even
in peak LA traffic.
I still have plenty of time.
A couple of things I want to
highlight here in terms of
what's happening behind
the scenes.
The reason why, from this
question, I could just get to
the answers in one step is
that Google is able to
understand when I say "my
flight" or "my hotel," it's
able to understand based on
the context that, hey, you
have a flight coming up, you
have a hotel reservation, and
use that information
to get the answer.
The second thing worth noting
here is that each of these
responses that Google is
giving back is very
structured.
So when you have the restaurant
reservation, it's
actually telling you the most
important things that you'd
want to know, like what time it
is, where it is, and even
get directions to get there.
Let's try a couple
more things.
What's on my schedule
this weekend?
COMPUTER VOICE: You have a
ticket for "Iron Man Three" at
9:30 PM tomorrow.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
All right.
So I can see that I have a movie
that my husband's taking
me tonight to make up for all
the long hours at work making
these demos work.
And I can also see again, to
reinforce the point, so when I
ask this question, what I want
to know are the most obvious
pieces of information that
I need as a user.
If I have a movie coming up, I
want to know the most obvious
things, which is what time it
is, where it is, and even
directions to get there, and
we're able to actually present
that structured information.
I can also see that there's
another event which is just my
usual regular yoga class
on Saturday.
It's coming from my
Calendar event.
I can also say, oh yeah, I
have this brunch with my
friends, again, like
where and when.
And I can say, oh yeah, there's
this event invitation
that I have for somebody's
birthday at my neighbor's.
This is a multiscreen
experience.
I just showed you on the phone,
I can speak these
questions and get an answer on
the phone, because usually
that's where you are
on the go, you want
the questions answered.
But I could just as well type
it in or even speak on the
laptop or desktop here.
In fact, why don't I actually
switch gears and show you a
couple examples just so you
know this is available
anywhere on Google.
So here I have my laptop.
I'm signed in.
I could say something like,
I could just type in.
And I see the same answer.
Because I typed in, I just see
the answer as a result.
Notice that I actually said a
slightly different thing.
I said, "when does my flight
leave," versus "when does my
flight land," and Google is
able to understand that.
I could also, again, speak
this on my laptop.
I could basically say, when
does my flight leave?
Let me try that again.
OK, Google.
When does my flight leave?
COMPUTER VOICE: Virgin America
flight 1930 from SFO to LAX
leaves at 8:00 AM tomorrow.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: And
so you notice that I can
basically speak to Google on
the laptop or on the phone.
I could also type it in.
Let me show you another
example.
I can basically say something
like, "my reservations."
And so right away, you see I
have a hotel reservation
coming up, the very one that I
was talking about earlier.
And again, I see all the
information that I need to be
able to act on that
information.
I have the restaurant
reservation coming up.
And I can type this in, and
again, Google understands when
I say "my," what do I mean when
I say "my reservations"
or "my hotels" and so on.
Let's switch gears.
So if you're a developer,
around this time, you're
thinking maybe a
couple things.
One, as a user, how
can I get to play
with these new features?
These are opt-in experiences
that we are actually building,
and we're building features
on top of it.
So at the end of the talk, I'm
going to give you instructions
on how to get in on the field
trial as a user on the how do
I actually ask Google for
information about myself,
about my own world?
Those of you who haven't tried
Google Now, you can actually
go to the Play Store and
download it and see some of
these contextual cards show up
as well so that you don't even
have to search for these.
On the day of the stay, you
should just get the hotel
information.
But as a developer, you're
wondering the other thing,
which is, if this is the new
Google, how can I be part of
this experience, and where
do you fit in here?
And here's the question that's
the most obvious one, which
is, you have all these
unstructured pieces of
information, and we need to be
able to turn these into really
structured answers.
And how does that happen,
and how do
developers be part of it?
And this is where email
markups come in.
The idea is very simple.
So for each of these use cases--
let's say the flight
or the hotel or the events--
we're saying, OK look.
For the user, these are the five
or six or 10 pieces of
information that are
really important.
So let's define a schema, a
vocabulary, for each of these
use cases and say, OK, for a
flight, we should be able to
define these particular
fields.
And you as the developer can
simply mark up the emails that
you already send your users and
say, this particular piece
of information is a passenger
name, this particular thing is
a reservation number,
and so on.
For a flight, for example, as a
user, I might type in, "when
is my next flight," and I want
to see the most basic pieces
of information.
The most obvious thing I just
want to know is which airline
am I flying on and what
flight number it is.
Some of the other pieces of
information I might want is
what time it is departing so
I'm not late, where it is
departing from, which airport,
and the same thing on the
landing side.
What airport is it landing at,
and what time it's landing at.
So on the right hand side here--
so left hand side is
what the user sees, and on the
right hand side, what you see
here is a very simple data
model, a schema, that says,
look, these are the pieces of
information that you want your
users to see so you can define
and you can basically mark up
your email along these
pieces of the schema.
So you have reservation number,
you have the flight
number, you have the airline's
name, departure time, arrival
time, and so on.
Really simple.
But this is for a flights
use case.
For a different type
of use case, like
an event, for example.
It'll take some time to load.
So let's say you
have an event.
Again, the user comes
into Google.
They can say, when is
the Giants game?
And we know, for example, that
they have a Giants game coming
up, and we can show the
structured answer here.
And if you see that answer,
again, the most important
pieces of information, what time
it is and where it is.
That's it.
So the right hand side, you
again have the most basic
pieces of information that you
as a developer can simply mark
up against information
you send.
When does it start and what's
the name and where is it?
This is for an events
use case.
Another one would be a hotel,
which we'll go into detail
with Roy's hands-on demo here.
Loading.
So another one can be a
restaurant reservation where
again, the basic pieces
of information.
Again, we start with the user
experience and say, what are
the pieces of information you as
a user would want, and then
work backwards and say, what
should be the fields in the
schema that you as a developer
should add?
Now, these are just an initial
subset of use cases that we
started out with.
Because we said, OK, we want
to start helping users, and
the most obvious pain point
we saw was travel.
Instead of futzing around with
the phone, we really wanted to
say, OK, through Google Now and
through these answers, we
want to start helping
the users.
But this is not the
comprehensive set here.
And I think this is one thing
where your inputs, your
creativity, your ideas would
be really useful, and we're
hoping that we can actually set
aside some time today to
discuss those.
What would be your example
of a use case?
What are some things that you
share information, that you
send information to users and
you don't want it lost in the
mix, gathering dust
in the inbox?
And how can we pick those
examples-- define the schema,
define the vocabulary
for those examples--
and then start building
new features?
So these are some really early
partners that we've actually
been working with in terms of
implementing markups, where
they're able to go from
unstructured information that
they send their users today to
these structured answers and
Google Now cards in
one single step.
Once they mark up these emails--
and we even have
tools that can help
with the markup--
and once they're able to do
the markup, they're done.
And what happens is the rest
of the hard work, they're
leaving to Google.
Bringing up this information
at the right time, doing
speech recognition, doing
natural language
understanding, the grunt
work there can be
dealt with by Google.
All you have to do as a
developer is basically take
the information you send already
and mark it up with
these basic pieces of
information, and you're done.
Now, I'm going to ask Roy to
actually walk you through a
couple of these examples, just
so you get a sense of how to
get started on these
as a developer.
Roy?
ROY LIVINE: Thanks, Aparna.
So let's say that you're an
online travel agency, and you
would like to get reservation
information available to users
through Google Now or through
answer in search.
So let's walk through the
process that booking.com, an
early adopter of our platform,
would have to go through if
they did this markup today.
So earlier this morning in the
Google Tools for Structured
Data, we introduced a really
new, cool tool called
Structured Data Markup Helper,
courtesy of these two
gentlemen in the first row.
So I will use this tool to
walk you through how
booking.com would mark
up their email.
So this is how the
tool looks like.
And as you can see, as Aparna
mentioned, we support four
different verticals, event
reservation, flight
reservation, lodging
reservation, and restaurant
reservation.
Since booking.com sends hotel
confirmation emails, I'm going
to click on the Lodging
Reservation.
So the input for this tool
is basically the
raw HTML of the email.
Now, I already prepared the
raw HTML of just a random,
regular booking.com hotel
reservation email.
I'll paste it in this box and
click on Start Tagging.
Take a few seconds to load,
more than a few seconds.
Let's just open another page.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Blame
it on the Wi-Fi.
ROY LIVINE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's going, Roy.
ROY LIVINE: It's going?
There it is.
OK, let's do it quickly
once again.
There you go.
Don't go away, please.
Bear with me.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Do
you want to hard-wire?
ROY LIVINE: Yeah, that should
be a good idea.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
There you go.
ROY LIVINE: OK.
So on the left hand side, you
can see what the users see
when they go to their
Gmail client.
It's just the email.
And on the right hand side, you
see the list of all the
fields that we support
for markup.
Now, our UI requires some of
the fields, and you can see
that the tool calls these out.
There are eight or nine
required fields here.
Let me quickly walk you through
the process of marking
up, and I'll show you
how easy it is.
We'll start with the
reservation number.
That's the first one.
I'll just click on the
reservation number, choose the
right field, and once I click,
you can see that the value is
updated on the right
hand side.
Let's quickly walk through
the rest of the fields.
Lodging name would be San
Francisco Marriott.
Street address.
AUDIENCE: Can you [? zoom in ?]
a little bit?
ROY LIVINE: Yeah.
That's a good idea.
How is that?
OK.
The city would be
San Francisco.
State, California.
Country and postal code.
Under name, that would be me.
And last is check-in time.
That's it.
So I'll just want to review
these to make sure that I
didn't forget any of
the fields, and it
looks like I didn't.
I'll click on Create HTML, and
what you see here are the few
lines that you'll have to
add to the top of your
email, and that's it.
Basically, your markup
is done.
It's as simple as that.
I think it's a good time to
mention that we support two
kinds of formats.
The traditional HTML we have
been supporting since we
introduced rich snippets.
And also, we decided to support
another format, JSON
LD, which some people feel
that it's easier to
understand, easier to implement
and to read.
If you do want to use JSON LD,
that's the default here.
And if you want to use microdata
HTML, you just have
to choose it.
What you see here on the right
hand side is just the raw HTML
with these few lines of HTML
markup added to the raw email.
There it is.
So just to recap, it's super
easy to implement this.
The tool that I just showed
you, the Markup Helper, is
already available in our
developer website.
And Iein's team also created
a validation tool.
Once you start to play with the
markup, you can copy the
markup that you created, paste
it into the Validation Tool
that's also in our developer
website, and see if you
actually marked up right.
And if you didn't, it'll tell
you what you did wrong so you
can fix it.
That's really easy.
Literally less than one day of
work for one engineer, and
this markup is done.
I hope you found it useful.
Thank you, and I'll hand
it over to Aparna.
[APPLAUSE]
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: So this
is the link that Roy was
talking about.
I want to step back and recap
what you just saw because I
think it's a big shift for where
Search is going, and
it's worth thinking about what
this means for you as users as
well as developers.
As users, I think the way to
think about this is the future
of Search is actually going
from questions to
answers in one step.
Behind the scenes, there's a
lot going on, but the main
point is you shouldn't have to
worry about it as users.
Let Google do the hard
work, and you
should get your answers.
And these answers, and the
answers that we focused on in
this session, for sure are for
answers about your own world,
your own information, but
they're answers from the rest
of the world from the
Knowledge Graph
that figure in, too.
I think in the same way, as
developers, what we want to
try and do is, how can you
actually make sure that the
information that you're sending
these users today,
it's lying in their inboxes, how
can we make sure that we
bring up the relevant
information into the search
box and into Google Now,
again, in one step?
So you should leave the rest
of the hard work to Google.
Actually, if you can just do the
markup on the emails that
you already send users, you're
basically good to go.
I'll leave you with two
concrete next steps.
One, as users, if you haven't
tried either Google Now or the
Search field trial, we have an
opt-in experience where once
you opt into this experience
at this short link here,
g.co/searchtrial, you will be
able to basically start
playing with this and
experimenting with features
that I just demoed.
You should be able to say,
when is my flight?
What's my schedule?
Show me emails from my friend.
So examples like that.
And then the second thing, as a
developer, one concrete next
step is we have actually an
entire developers' website
dedicated to going through all
of this in detail, all the
tools and the documentation
on the schema that we've
developed for these
initial use cases.
But also, we're actually
starting a small pilot program
to sign up partners.
Some of these partners are
on board, as you saw.
But definitely, sign up to be
part of the program and work
together with us so that you can
see how to start surfacing
in Google Now and search.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: So I think
we have maybe time for
Q&A if you want to raise
any questions.
Otherwise, we're also back
in the Sandbox area where
Knowledge is, and you can come
talk to us about any of these
questions in detail.
And if there's anything you know
from this talk, we love
answering questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I wonder if you could comment on
the roadmap for new schemas
and whether there's a schedule
of coming schemas.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Sorry.
Can you say that again?
AUDIENCE: I wonder if you could
comment on the roadmap
for schemas.
Right now, I saw I think
four examples.
I think yesterday we saw some
examples of media and music.
Is there a roadmap
for schemas?
Is there a schedule?
If you could comment on the
plans of the future.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: So the
question was yesterday in the
keynote, you saw some of these
other examples of your own
information being very easy,
like one of the specific demos
we saw was, show me
my pictures from
New York last year.
And instead of, again, futzing
through albums and albums,
we're just basically doing the
hard look and saying, look,
here you go.
And today, you saw these other
kinds of examples.
And the question was,
is there a roadmap?
What's the bigger
picture here?
The way we think about this
problem, again, is starting
with the user and saying, what
are the typical daily
information needs
that a user has?
Now it turns out, we actually
did a bunch of user studies
around this.
We found that some of
these user needs are
about the real world.
They say basically, how is the
traffic to this place, or
what's the GDP of
that country?
Is the restaurant open?
But many of these questions,
what we found from our user
studies, are about their
own information.
Especially as that information
keeps growing, their need to
find that information grows.
So some of this information
is photos, is media.
Other pieces of information are
in their emails, typically
events and other travel-related
questions.
There are other verticals
or use cases that we've
identified, and we're starting
to work on them.
And the reason we've actually
done a field trial of these is
to say, OK, let's put it in
front of our users for the use
cases that we can start
unlocking and see how the
reaction is.
How do people actually use
this, and how do people
actually find this information
useful?
So over the next few months and
until the end of the year,
we're going to start expanding
these use cases.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you've showed how we can
register information that's
later recalled from Google
Now or through the
Google search tools.
Are there other interfaces--
are there programmatic
interfaces-- to allow
developers to be able to pull up
that information that maybe
was registered by other
applications?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: That's
a good question.
So the question, as I
understand it is,
look, this is great.
One obvious surface is through
the search tools and Google
Now, but are there other APIs
for developers to actually
surface that information?
I think the way to think about
this is, again, componentizing
these pieces of information.
For example, once Chrome gets
the microphone icon, then
through the Chrome APIs, you
should basically be able to
say your own website
should get you the
capability to do voice.
And again, you should rely on
Google to do the hard work in
terms of actually having the
underlying technology, but
then you should just worry
about the responses that
you're going to generate
for the user.
So the way I think about the
problem is more, what's the
most obvious surface where the
users are actually looking for
this information?
Start there.
Help them there.
And then figure out if there
are other places
that we can help them.
AUDIENCE: So I was interested
in the Schema Helper.
You showed only four helpers
that were specifically tied to
events and reservations.
Are there any plans of
adding more such
helpers in the near future?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Yes.
Do you have any ideas on what
kinds of other use cases?
AUDIENCE: For example,
products.
If you sell products, then you
could send the schema for a
product on the email.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Yes.
So the question is in the Helper
tool, you saw we had a
few use cases--
events, hotels, flights,
restaurants.
The question was, well, why
don't we have helpers for
other use cases?
This is exactly the kind of back
and forth conversation
we'd love to have in the
developer community which is,
what are the other use cases?
Products would be a really
good one, where there's a
purchase order, for example.
AUDIENCE: So it will work
as a conversation?
We ask and you develop?
Or will we have APIs to build
our own helpers and maybe add
them to the tool?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: In the
beginning-- and Justin, feel
free to jump in here.
MALE SPEAKER: One comment.
I saw before for email-oriented
schemas
[INAUDIBLE]
conditional schemas that are
more [INAUDIBLE] oriented.
[INAUDIBLE].
So we don't have current plans
to open up [INAUDIBLE]
schema process.
[INAUDIBLE]
it would be challenging,
but [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Tim.
Question.
How does it define what
information is shown on the
main part of the search and
which one is shown on the
right side?
So for example, if I look for
flight information, it
currently displays in the main
search area, and some
information is shown
on the right.
And related to that is,
what if you have
multiple matching results?
So I have multiple flights in
different sites, or it could
be products or whatever.
How is that being handled?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: So two
parts to your question.
One is, when do we basically
figure out, how do we figure
out and what's the logic in
terms of when we bring up the
information front and
center versus when
we think it's auxiliary.
And what you are referring to is
in fact in the field trial.
For certain queries or certain
questions, we think there is a
very strong explicit intent.
For example, if you say, "When
does my flight land," I mean,
there's no question that you're
asking about the flight.
But if you said "Virgin America"
because you wanted to
basically look up the customer
service number, we don't want
to get in the way.
Again, this is Google,
this is search.
We definitely don't want to be
getting in the way between
your question and answer, and we
want to be doubly sure that
we understood the intent
of your question.
So if your question is, when is
my flight, then we'll say,
OK obviously, you're looking for
the flight, so let's give
you that answer and get
out of the way.
But if your question starts
with "Virgin America" or
"Virgin America Customer Service
Number," then we think
that if this information is
helpful, then we basically
give you in the auxiliary
in the right hand side.
But in general, we try to
actually get closer and closer
to your explicit intent
as much as possible.
And this is where the natural
language helps because when
you're expressing questions or
queries in natural language,
there's very little doubt
what you mean.
So for example, if you wanted
to know the customer service
number, if you're able to say
this to Google, you would.
If you're able to say to Google,
what's the customer
service number of Virgin
America, you would.
And that's hard.
It takes some early steps,
but the natural language
technology is not
fully there yet.
And the other thing you
mentioned was around, how do
we make sure that the
information is represented?
AUDIENCE: No.
I mean, I could have more
than one match.
So one example is the data about
contacts you're showing
on the right side now.
What if you have multiple
matches or multiple
applications that provide
the same information?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Yeah,
and we love that use case
because it actually
shows off--
so in fact, in the demo if
you saw, I typed in "My
Reservations," and I had a hotel
reservation, I had a
restaurant reservation.
We showed both of those
because you said, "My
reservations." Or if you said my
flights, and you're a busy
bee, and you have five flights
coming up in the next month,
we basically want to give you
all the information you need.
And in fact, I can show you how
each of these pieces of
information, you can expand and
say-- and I can certainly
show you the link later--
but expand the information in
place so that you could see
all the relevant information
about a flight and go on to
the next one and so on.
So the way we basically figure
out is based on the query that
you have-- if you said "My
flight tomorrow," it'll give
you just that.
But if you said "My flights
next month," then we
understand that and say
here, all of it.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Just another quick one.
So you mentioned about multiple
events around something.
What about events that
change information?
My reservation changes,
things like that.
How do I, as a developer, go
back and update it so I'm not
having outdated information
shown to users?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: That's a
really good point because I
think in all of these use cases,
reservations or events,
and that's precisely why
markup is helpful.
So once you actually give the
email and you're able to mark
up the updated email that you
send the users, we're able to
figure it out and say, OK, this
is obviously the latest
information here.
ROY LIVINE: So if you think
about it, our API is actually
the emails that you're
sending out.
If you want to update the
reservation, just send an
email, and we will do all
the heavy lifting.
We'll understand that this
is actually the previous
reservation if you provide the
confirmation number, and then
we will be able to update
the card in Search
and in Google Now.
So really, the emails
are your APIs.
AUDIENCE: So the assumption is
that that should be taken care
of as long as we have sent some
sort of a follow-up tied
to some kind of key?
ROY LIVINE: Exactly.
And you mark up.
You'll have to mark up so that
we can understand and dedupe.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So this is maybe a
different kind of use case.
At one point, Google, I think,
had a tool that would index
all the information on my
computer because you can't
remember all the stuff
that's in there.
And I don't know whether that
tool even still exists, but I
wind up keeping things in my
inbox as a reminder of things
I need to do.
Or I even send myself emails
just to remind me of something
to do or to keep track of a
small piece of information
that otherwise would be lost.
Because at least if it's in my
Gmail, I can search on it.
But for instance, I can't find
that out if I'm away from
home, and I just
have my phone.
But have you ever thought about
that aspect of this?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: So there
are two parts to what you're
asking, and the question or the
topic that you've brought
up is, my inbox has a
lot of information.
Some of it is very actionable
in terms of the information
that I need for a flight, but a
lot of it is just my backup
to my brain, just information
that I've sent there, and I
know it's safe, and I know
it's in the inbox.
It won't go away.
I could come back to it.
Are we doing anything
better there?
So there are two parts here.
One is if you have attended
the other talk we had
yesterday around actions and
inbox, so one of the things
we're trying to make is make
the inbox more alive.
So for example, don't
let the to do list
gather dust in the inbox.
Actually resurface it at
a time that's most
appropriate to you.
The second part of it is, in
fact, we just launched a new
version of Google Now yesterday
in the latest
release of the client,
and we have a
feature called Reminders.
And the idea is really simple.
You should be able to tell
Google, hey, remind me to call
mom when I get home, and have
that be surfaced as
a Google Now card.
And down the line, we want to
be able to actually use
information, again, in your
inbox because you told us
that's important, and use that
to, again, resurface good,
actionable to do lists for
you in Google Now.
AUDIENCE: It's sort
of an ordeal to
give myself that reminder.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
Right, exactly.
You shouldn't have to.
Yes, exactly.
Last question.
Make it good.
AUDIENCE: So I'm thinking
about attachments.
So a lot of us have attachments,
text documents,
that have information that we
want to look for, but the mail
would just have an attachment,
and there's no way--
I would need to figure out a
good keyword to look for that
mail, remember who that person
sent that mail to search for a
keyword that's in
the attachment.
So is there work?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: We don't
have anything at this point,
but I think definitely, that's
one of the things we do see is
that a lot of the information is
actually in these auxiliary
parts of the email,
and we should be
able to actually surface.
And the way to think about this
is we just don't want the
work to be in your head and
make it easy for you to
actually pretty much give us a
few shorthands saying, OK, who
is this from?
What is this about?
And then we should
do the hard work.
AUDIENCE: Just show
some metadata.
That will make it easier for the
user to search for things.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Nothing
yet, but definitely something
we're thinking about.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: We're out
of time, but again, we're
in the Sandbox area.
Any questions, thoughts, ideas
around new use cases, come
talk to us.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]